so freunde die skisaison hat angefangen
die pisten sind voll und die
krankenhäuser auch warum das werde ich
mir jetzt erklären lassen von dr
weerberg
wie geht es ihnen erst einmal
wir haben hier persönlich geht es ganz
gut unseren kliniken ist die vier
kliniken hier in der region rosenheim
geht es nicht so gut ist also quasi
schon jetzt so dass man eigentlich
keinen mehr aufnehmen kann wir haben
hier beispielsweise in rosenheim haben
wir normalerweise 67 betten für die
unfallchirurgie die sind in dieser
jahreszeit
typischerweise ganz gut voll von denen
können wir im moment 35 betreiben weil
der rest einfach wegfällt weil david
patienten drin liegen weil wir betten
sperren mussten weil wir kein personal
haben ich als araber darf hier leider
sieht es da nicht besser deswegen werde
ich dieses jahr schiefer zum ersten mal
in meinem leben er und da will ich sie
gerne bitten ob sie mir vielleicht einen
platz auf der intensivstation
reservieren können
also für den fall des falles ich bin mir
sicher da passiert nichts ich bin
nämlich also was bewegung angeht und
da bin ich wirklich ganz vorne mit dabei
wieso naturtalent wie sie brauche ich da
wahrscheinlich nichts zu reservieren
[Musik]
haben sie denn tipps für mich wie ich
unfallfrei schief gegangen ich würde
sagen auf jeden fall skilanglauf vor
apache das heißt das also einfach eine
ebene straße das ist dann so gerade mit
einer loipe gespurt und dann macht man
da so eine relativ synchrone bewegungen
mit zum abdrücken damit können sie gut
loslegen sind im schnee haben spaß und
haben eine relativ geringe gefahr dass
sie sich tatsächlich verletzten
[Musik]
die schlimmsten verletzungen die leute
haben schulter kopf
[Musik]
kreuzbands ein thema
das den leuten heute vorsicht hier die
intensivstation sind alle voll
also bei mir ist bis jetzt ehrlich
gesagt noch nie was passiert doch sei
die intensivstation ein wenn ihm etwas
passieren sollte der hand versteuerung
jacke reist knie sehen anderes
bandscheibenvorfall kreuzbandriss da
wird das jemand braucht dann müssen sie
leider sich damit einverstanden erklären
dass wir sie auf eine intensivstation
nach russland nordkorea oder
das mache ich nicht
einmal das heinrich weitergehen
es geht um unsere sicherheit
zugspitze unfallfrei dass sie uns und
garantieren dass wir heute keine oder
unfall machen und wenn sie einen unfall
machen dass wir dann eine notfallstation
intensivstation in russland nordkorea
oder dubai belegen
ich glaube der traut dem braten nicht so
richtig damit kannst du wieder in china
dies hier
ist jeder dabei
schwere handarbeit und mit dem mund
abreisen ja das sind die meisten das
plastik das kommt den sondermüll und
dabei interessieren
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und was ist für sie ihr gefährlich
skifahren oder böllern zu silvester
produziert augenverletzungen an
verletzungen und ähnliches das kann im
einzelfall alles auch futter scheußlich
sein aber das steht jetzt in keinem
verhältnis zu einem ein wochen- oder
monatelang skizirkus mit apres ski etwas
finden sie eigentlich besser um eine
intensivstation zu entlasten sie verbot
oder böller verbote
der bruderhaus die klaren ansagen die
partner die situation ist sehr schwierig
und bedeutet leider auch die skisaison
viel mehr arbeit für das personal auf
intensivstationen deswegen unsere
gelegenheit erst wenn sie möchten mit
mir gemeinsam in die kamera für das
personal zu klatschen damit sie mit
unserem klatschen die miete bezahlen
können
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk